[Laughter]
it's gonna be great wait is it like live
right now yeah yeah we're like but
there's pre-roll is there a club can you
tell us there's audio hey Jerrod
where does it say oh it says that there
are no people here that's weird
oh there are people tuning in so you'll
be able to see this is what happens
before every live stream i've ever
watched which is like oh I see three
people alright so my name is Estelle
Caswell I'm a video producer a box and I
make earworm um so I guess really what
I'm here to do is just answer any
question you might have that relates to
my job at bucks what I do what my
coworkers do and thank you for coming
and joining and becoming a member this
is like a huge experiment this is the
first time I've ever done a live AMA so
hopefully it's entertaining and
informative and hey stay tuned so let's
figure out what some questions might be
so Jumeirah has a question which is i'd
love to ask her how long it usually
takes to create a video from idea to
upload and what's consistently the most
challenging part throughout the process
okay um this is like a three-part
question but I would say from beginning
to end the video process is ideally like
three weeks but I would say more often
than not I'm doing a lot of research
while I'm working on other projects so
the more research time I have
usually the more long like the longer
the video is and typically I can't stop
researching so a lot of the time that
three weeks might turn into four or five
weeks and from I would say the vast
majority of the like project is in the
research and the writing phase and then
I spend as much time as I can animating
and editing but I usually don't leave
myself enough time to do that until I'd
say what's the most consistently most
challenging part of the process um I
would say my strengths are in editing
and animating and so the most
challenging part but often the most
rewarding if I can nail it and get it
right is writing I really enjoy the
process of writing but it's certainly
the thing that takes me the most time I
don't have any like muscle memory when
it comes to writing so I always feel
like I'm sort of reinventing the wheel
or trying to figure out better ways to
research or outline my projects so yeah
writing is definitely the most
challenging but whenever I get it right
I know I get it right and that feels
really rewarding um let's see what skill
of yours do you find to be most useful
as a producer um well whenever I started
at Bucks I was actually hired to be an
animator so it's a skill that I have
that helps me out the most is animation
only because if I have an idea I'm
usually able to execute it visually and
I would say it's also the part of the
process that I'm very much willing to
spend all my doing um as I often get
carried away and I forget how long it
takes to do things but I would say
that's also been my most useful skill is
I can pull off some pretty fun things
visually as an animator what do I like
about producing maybe the thing that I
like the most is
[Music]
not a bit let's see I think the most
exciting part is like after I finish a
script going into the vo booth and remit
script got wild and realizing like like
in my head how everything is gonna
really like feel like a cohesive piece
so I would say the moment between like
finishing the vo and editing the like
first draft of the video is like my most
favorite part of producing which I guess
and like I think a lot of people don't
really understand what a video producer
does and that's because the term
producer is very it fluctuates from job
to job but for the most part a box a
producer is the person that comes up
with the idea for the story and in most
cases executes it's the whole thing
or total to publish and the people
involved in that process our story
editors who help like manage the script
and make sure it's as clear and tight as
possible and then kind of trim away the
fat the things that you really love but
probably aren't super necessary to the
story and when possible people to help
shoot interviews and if you're like me
and sometimes promise a deadline that
might not be possible other people to
pitch in on the animation let's see what
are some other questions woods Oh which
one but I would say like one thing that
people ask me a lot is how to how do I
come up with stories so I would say most
of my time spent on a like coming up
with ideas is really just listening to
music and a lot of the time would have
been doing recently is listen to like
entire discographies of artists rather
than like a very famous album because
you really kind of figure out what maybe
their sound how how it has evolved or
really interesting aspects of their
music that people might not often pick
up on because they listen to all of it
and the other thing I do is I do really
deep dives into genres of music that I
don't listen to just in my free time so
a lot of what I do at work is just open
Spotify and listen to lots of music that
I wouldn't necessarily listen to on a
regular day-to-day basis but that might
be significant in terms of like music
history and usually the way I come up
with stories it's like I really fixate
on sounds rather than like what an
artist might be known for um or like
their personality or things like that
so usually I kind of try to figure out
like what trends did they start or are
were part of and I would say my favorite
like eras of music that I often dip into
and love to tell stories about are like
from 1979 to 1990 like the era of music
where digital technology be kind of
mashed up against like when people
started making music for much cheap much
more cheap like they they had
instruments that they could buy and just
make an entire song on like a drum
machine or synthesizer rather than have
to like book a studio and have all these
like really expensive piece of equipment
so like that Eric music for me is really
interesting
right for some really cool stories like
gated reverb or the orchestra head stuff
like that um what's the most fulfilling
part of creating these videos for you um
I would say I think just being able to
be very curious at my job that's like
the coolest thing and it's probably the
most fulfilling I feel like every day I
come to work and I'm able to like you
know buy a book and read the whole thing
and learn a lot and then just be able to
like regurgitate that in the most
creative way I possibly can through a
video um and for me that's really
fulfilling because I feel like I I'm
like a well of a lot of random pieces of
information and I love that about my job
it allows me to do that see is there a
video you go back there's our video you
can go back and change Y T on we
standing right there a video I'd go back
and change I think there are certain
videos that I wish I could have made a
lot longer or included a really
interesting piece of information I'd say
probably like the rapping
constructed video I hate to say this but
I would go back and like redo the vo
because it was the it was the moment
when I like started understanding how
videos should be to look like voiceovers
should be delivered and I think that was
whenever I like was in this middle
ground between like having a lot of
energy and a voiceover and understanding
how to like be very clear and whenever I
still feel like I probably sounded like
a baby
oh I'd probably go back and change the
voice over on the wrapkin deconstructed
um how many people have gifted you Grey
Poupon after your video on whatever at
Percy's okay so if you don't know the
Grey Poupon video basically it's a story
about how rappers reference the Dijon
mustard and hip hop like way more than
Dijon mustard is actually relevant to
your everyday life and sort of tracing
the story of that and so it was kind of
like in my first original piece of
recording where I came up with my own
Veda set and I like scrubbed rap lyrics
and I like came up with this chart that
didn't exist before and surprisingly
nobody has sent me Grey Poupon I'm sure
I gave a lot of really great um like
brand awareness to the mustard and I've
not gotten one free products from that
so it was worth it by not for free free
stuff which one should I do
what's oh I think I did that one
Oh Johnny you make a lot of important
videos critical of tech got any ideas
for videos featuring positive aspects of
tech um I guess not really I don't
really understand that question um yeah
I don't know how I might be if you could
clarify that specific or what video
you're talking about that'd be good yeah
I'm just like reading all of the
questions you're thinking try to figure
out one oh how long have you worked at
fox for Buck's Alexander I worked at Fox
since 2014
and I started as a freelancer I was an
animator so basically what I did I think
maybe the first video I worked on was
one that was it's like an animated
explainer about what the anti-vaxxer
movement was about and it's really fun
and I did it in like five days and it
was just kind of like a really cool
crash course in visual journalism and I
kind of got hooked on that process and
joined Fox a couple of months later as a
full-time animator and from there on out
I guess from the end of 2014 till now
I'm just sort of like developed as a
journalist wherein before I was really
like my whole career was geared towards
working and advertising and doing like
really cool like commercial animation
and the thing that I felt really fell in
love with very quickly it's like a short
form documentary and coming like not
just being the animator on it on a story
but actually telling it and reporting it
and coming up with really interesting
ways to grab people's attention what's
my favorite lacroix flavor brain
I can't pronounce that username it's
right now the quarry flavor is lime so
that's my favorite because it was the
one that was available to me
Florian Ferran burger asks I assume you
have a ton of topics and ideas floating
around at bugs what is the process of
picking one to actually tackle and what
percentage does make an introduction
that is a really good question so the
way we pitch stories is typically - our
story editor for me that is Mona and so
you'll often see her name on the credits
of all of my videos and what I do is I
spend a little time researching
something enough to figure out if it
actually has a lot of meat to its story
and if there's an interesting like
reveal or a moment that kind of flips
your perspective on what a sound where a
sound came from or like how it's sort of
affected music or was a part of music
history and I would say most of the time
I won't pitch something unless I know
it's a really good story so often it's
me trying to figure out if I feel like
it's worth making a part of an earworm
episode versus like um just doing it's a
one-off and another time but I would say
the the biggest like challenge of that
process is really having like all of the
visuals in all of the evidence to show
people and to get to get you all engaged
with the story and sort of get it so
like an example would be the orchestra
head video where I had actually thought
about that story for a really long time
whenever I was doing the gated reverb
video I came across this sound so I was
like a full year prior but it wasn't
until like nine months later where I was
like okay that might actually be a story
I should start digging into that and
what I found I kind of like
thought about it for even a couple of
months after that so it was a full year
of me sort of thinking about it and not
really fully creating a story or a pitch
around it until I had the time and I was
like okay I'll do this I'll try and see
if there's an actual thing here so there
are a lot of sounds in my head that I
think there might be stories but I just
haven't gotten to actually like digging
in and doing the research on it that
probably was a very bad answer to that
question
um oh thanks so much Gavin for shouting
us out
hi Gavin oh oh that's oh my god I just
read your last name Gavin used to work
for us that's a nice
Samuel Goodwin do you all ever think of
making a video on the effort to
transform to a circular economy it's a
topic that may be vitally important if
not our future I had a lot of difficulty
restrain myself oh my gosh
I am NOT the person has to scratch chin
but hopefully Samuel will have a wife am
a with somebody who might be interested
in that topic and they will definitely
will save it for someone who might be
better suited to ask it um Ashley Walker
once the production work low throw flow
like from start to finish for video um
the production workflow is really just
like sitting by my desk and coming up
with stories listening to a lot of you
take pitching Brad story in a sort of
really structured race or like really
understanding if it's worth making for a
video doing all of the pre reporting so
calling a lot of people and interviewing
them about their expertise on the
subject and sometimes those people make
it into the videos and sometimes it's
really just information gathering so for
instance for the smooth jazz video a
Murray the AP on this story helped me
interview like it felt like
half a dozen people and only three made
it into the final cut but we did do a
lot of like research by talking to
people and reporting and then from there
it's really all about like compiling all
of that information into the most clear
cohesive way possible that still feels
like really entertaining and that kind
of is manifested in a script and then an
audio cut which is really just my vo
with all the sort of fun musical cues
and things like that and then from there
we'll go from premiere which is our
editing program that we use and into
After Effects and start covering those
holes in the video that we've left for
animation and that process like the
editing and animating process is
typically like a week to a week and a
half if I can do it quickly which
sometimes I just cannot do it quickly oh
that was that was a question from Ashley
oh cool so Theo
hey Rachel install congrats on Ihram a
pitch worthy series since your contact
pose a lot of music I assume you're an
avid listener what makes a song stand
out and become video worthy that is a
really good question and for me there's
a lot of criteria one would be that a
lot of people know this song so it might
like sometimes like the hooks into a
certain story are like a really popular
song but then throughout the video I'll
reference other music that might not be
as well known but it still fits into the
story in some way shape or form
so like the orchestra hit video most of
the songs I selected we're like on this
top 40 charts in some way shape or form
so like that's kind of a big factor for
me
another is that it was if it was like
part of a moment in time in music that
is like historically significant or
helped transform music in some way shape
or form
or was effective or influential or
represents a moment and music really
really well so like I would say Phil
Collins's in the air tonight it was a it
was like a really culturally significant
song in a lot of ways but what for me
would that story really represented was
just like the one moment in the song
where the gated reverb drum drums come
in and so whenever I pick songs I
usually pick like a really small snippet
that you can sort of like zoom into and
grab and tell a story of that versus
like maybe the song itself it's more
like the sounds in the song that I
gravitate towards and I would say
certain songs I just really loved
because I would say like for the triplet
video I didn't have to use notorious
b.i.g s and Bone Thugs and harmony I
think the song is called notorious thugs
I didn't have to use that in the video
but I really loved that song and I and I
wanted to make that a really cool like
moment to break apart help triplet how
the triplet rap flow works so sometimes
I just tried to like plug my favorite
songs into videos to illustrate a point
because I think it makes it more
exciting for me to like talk about the
story that is a long-winded way of
saying there's a lot of reasons and I
think a lot of it just has to do with
whether a lot of people will sort of
connect with it um let's see
Alexandre hastily currently I'm looking
for a career that will feel fulfilling
to me I thought about a few different
paths
and I'm starting to set my site on
journalism so I guess my question is
what is the most challenging part of
your job and what is the most rewarding
do you have much freedom in your work I
would say the most challenging part of
my job is for me it's like constantly
not getting not getting overwhelmed with
thinking too much about it um I've
gotten to the point where like a lot of
the time I only really think about
stories and I can be like at a dinner
with a friend or at a museum and I'm
like still thinking about ways I can
relate a conversation or something that
I saw to story that I could tell so I
would say in journalism that's like a
really fun thing because it's if you
love telling stories and the world is
sort of your playground for ideas but it
also can kind of become overwhelming
because you can think about it way too
much and not have a good work-life
balance but I would say what's the most
rewarding part of my job is that it's
like endlessly creative and I have a lot
of autonomy and the types of stories
that I get to tell and the way I want to
shape what I'm interested in and how I
can sort of like form that into a career
and so one thing what we talked a lot
about on the team is like how can you
get better at a specific meet and for me
like I had no idea I would be a music
journalist two years ago I like really
did in the rapping deconstructed video
was the first video that I published
about music and it was one of three
pitches that had like one of them was
rap focused and then the other two had
nothing to do with pop culture at all
and my teammates were like that's really
interesting you should go with that and
I made it and people really loved it and
I realized I really loved making it and
that sort of sparks sort of created a
like the next two years of me being like
oh I should really focus on telling
stories about music because I enjoyed it
and I
want to get better at it and so I think
that's probably the most rewarding is
you can you can really shape your what
you're interested in into like an actual
career path by just like developing an
expertise and a beat Alexis what's the
most difficult part for you when making
a video I mentioned this before I would
say the most difficult part is like the
term like throwing away your babies the
idea that I've learned so much when I'm
researching and not all of it can fit
into a script and so the most
challenging part for me is really like
writing the script and always keeping
you all in mind as an audience because I
could probably every one of my videos
would probably be like 25 minutes and
way more boring if I didn't have a story
editor who actually was like that's a
really interesting fun fact but it has
nothing to do with this story
you should probably cut it out and my
heart is the hardest thing that has too
much this like realize that they are
correct
so yeah scripting is probably the most
challenging part um spring day one is
the user okay what songs do you use to
try out new headphones bubbles by Yosi
or Cola is a must for me to hear how
they care perform that is a really
interesting question
and I think it might be really
embarrassing for me to admit this but
they do not think about headphones at
all um I have a really great pair of
headphones and they're like the sony MDR
or something or another I never think
about testing out using certain songs to
test out headphones but that is a really
good idea I think one that I would
probably one song that I'd probably
think about
uh I'm gonna say drunken love by Beyonce
it's a it's a pop song so you know it's
gotta like play really well on a lot of
different speakers but I think some like
it's really really fun to listen to
not just the lyrics but the actual like
production of it um Bridgette henwood
who's on our team she's a story editor
did you play an instrument high school
band if not what do you think you would
have played I did um from the age of
five till about 14 I played piano and um
I think I'm if I could go back in time I
would take it way more seriously I think
a lot of like people who grew up and
they're kind of like forced to play
piano as a kid I actually don't learn a
lot of music theory you just sort of
learned how to sight read and play just
sort of like regurgitate popular songs
so I played a lot of like Hey Jude by
the Beatles and did not learn any music
theory at all so yeah I played piano and
then I tried to learn guitar I thought
that would be really cool and then it
hurt my fingers so bad that I gave it up
in a week and what I didn't care about
at all is that the guitar teacher was
like you just develop calluses on your
on your fingertips and it won't hurt
after a while and I was like I don't
care I don't want to do that at all I
don't care enough about the guitar to
develop calluses on my fingertips yeah I
really wish I would have stuck with
piano and actually learns the music
theory when I had the chance because now
I'm like learning music theory without
having a piano in front of me to really
implement it and and learn um Alexis do
you only work on one video at a time or
do you have several projects at the same
time I would say I have several projects
at the same time so actually right now
I'm developing ideas for ear worm season
too
and there's like eight or so ideas that
I'm currently in the process of
researching with a Murray and we're kind
of doing this sort of initial phase of
like they carrying out the outlines for
each of the stories what are the pieces
of archive or visuals that really pair
well with them and who are the experts
that we can do a lot of pre reporting
like just reaching out and asking a
bunch of questions about the subject
matter so when it comes to like
pre-production I typically work on a lot
at the same time but the second that I
have to start actually making the video
like going into the vo booth editing and
stuff I really can only work out on one
at a time because it's it's hard to
explain but animating and editing is
like you need to have pure tunnel vision
and you really can't multitask while
you're doing it or at least I can't
and so I'll spend like you know a full
80 hour vote like 80 hours straight just
in the in the Edit and animating without
working on anything else
Laurie Ness what's your favorite movie
soundtrack and why oh that's a really
good question
oh my god I'm gonna have to think about
this I would say this is really hard
today
what's
shaft really kids movie soundtrack who
did that was that um Isaac Hayes
somebody so I need some fact check I
think that's I think it would be that
Isaac Hayes's soundtrack for shaft it's
perfect
and actually I would say all of his
music is like incredible and if you
haven't ever listened to all of us at
case you should do that in one fell
swoop because it will change your
perspective on music for sure
Meo asks Oh follow up being part of your
non-us audience do you have plans to
focus some episodes of earworm on music
that might be popular elsewhere in the
world but not specific to the US
absolutely um I think one of the like
biggest challenges for me is that part
of my job like part of what I do
requires so much time and effort that I
wish I could like go travel and learn
about music
and other parts of the world and like
speak to the people who actually really
know it firsthand New York City is a
really great city to explore that idea
for at least some different cultures
because there is a melting pot city and
there are a lot of really great experts
in music from various parts of the world
I would say one two episodes at least
next year in season two will focus on
music that's outside of the bounds of
the US hopefully more but hopefully
that'll be like a sneak peek into what
might possibly what those episodes might
possibly be about I think one of them
will definitely delve into the music
theory how how like what
stern music really focuses on a certain
set of rules where Eastern music focuses
on a different set of music theory
principles and then some will have to do
more cultural stories like different
genres of music that have developed
outside of the US or who traveled really
well outside of the u.s. Matthew asks a
question are all video producers
responsible for their own motion
graphics um that's like it's very
circumstantial so for me I I really like
being responsible for my own motion
graphics because I love animating in
some cases some producers will
collaborate with somebody who might have
more time to animate the project than
they do so yeah pretty much
for the most part everybody on the team
can animate in some capacity and so we
all touch our videos animations for the
most part but some people hand off their
stuff to others this user name is cell
SEL 18 do you see the graphics in your
mind as you hear the music you're doing
a video on
I would I guess what the question might
be is like can't do I visualize each
scene before
I'm actually like animating it and that
answer to that is yes whenever I'm
writing in scripts kind of all required
to do this on air cam is will write a
script and then will write all the
visuals that will go in the story and
for me I like to be in some cases like
very metaphorical so like one example
would be the John Coltrane Giant Steps
video where I actually worked with a
really cool animator Ariel Costa who my
idea was that I would have John Coltrane
like climb up a pyramid of album covers
and jazz things like instruments and
stuff and he pulled that idea off um so
it was kind of like a weird thing that I
had in my head and it was a way to sort
of like visualize this idea of this
album being like the pinnacle of jazz
and that was an idea I had like really
early on in the scripting process and I
just wrote it out and he was able to
implement it um yeah but for the most
part like everything is sort of
pre-planned in my head and whenever I
don't have that it takes me way longer
to figure out what to do
and that's whenever I miss my deadlines
[Music]
Alexander do you like ambient or eidm
great genre terrible name music if so
what is your favorite project ambient um
what is I DM I do love ambient music um
I would say I guess like one artist that
I often listen to a lot while I'm like
sort of zoning out this next one who is
like kind of the Godfather of that music
and I would say although DJ shadow is
definitely more hip-hop I really I
his music to be very ambient and so I
listen to him a lot too and I'm getting
more into it but oh intelligent dance
music I I want to know more about this
I've never heard of intelligent dance
music is that just like like like more
pretentious dance music I don't see on
what is that a sex twins oh it is like a
best friend let's see um yeah I've
listened to a lot of these artists I did
not know that they were called
intelligent stands intelligent dance
music Flying Lotus yes I love flying
lettuce for Tet absolutely these are I'm
definitely like mentioning the more
famous mainstream artist John Hopkins I
really love John Hopkins I'm looking at
Google's interpretation of what
intelligent dance music is maybe they're
not actual intelligent dance music
artists Boards of Canada yeah I guess
the answer to that is yes I do like IDM
Florian in your videos you interview
some fairly famous artists how do you
approach them to ask if they're up for
something like this how much of the
story do you pitch them or in the case
of rapping deconstructed I interviewed
open mike eagle it was the first time I
ever interviewed an like an actual
artist before and I would say the way I
pitched his
[Music]
luckily like during promo for an album
and he was in town and so it like just
worked out that he was able to like come
to our office and luckily he was like
just the best person ever and we had a
really cool conversation that felt like
we were able to just nerd out on things
that we had in common and were able to
enjoy so read typically pitch people is
like you have expertise in this area and
I just really want to hear your
perspective on the story and sometimes
it works and sometimes nobody responds
and that's just what happened for Big
Freedia on the bounce episode we reached
out and she was actually doing a show in
Brooklyn as well so it just a lot of the
time I look at like tour dates and see
if people are in town and it's more
likely that they'll say yes in in that
case um and that was another thing where
it took a while and it was like a little
awkward at first but once I think the
biggest thing is like I did a ton of
research on that story before I went
into the room and asked questions and
what I really found helped is like I ask
the questions that they might not often
get asked a lot of times artists get
asked the same questions over and over
again and I try to like dig a little
deeper than that one of my favorite
music interviewers is Nord water and
he's like it's crazy awesome right he
does like uncanny research on these
artists and he's sort of known for being
like knowing information about them that
they probably never revealed the other
people so it's kind of creepy but he
always surprises like everybody from
like Drake to jay-z and like his music
knowledge and it's like a really cool
person to rock
his YouTube videos because he's like a
really good interviewer and very
persistent in the most entertaining way
spring day one I'd love if you could do
an episode about Roland Kirk or moon dog
interesting all right all right at um
Matthew following up on the motion
graphics side what is your background
with motion graphics any resources Fox
suggests a level of pure motion graphics
abilities so I'm like the film school
and in four years I didn't I never
opened After Effects and I realized
after I graduated that I wanted to do
Russian graphics so the year after I
graduated I taught myself and I would
say the biggest piece of advice is like
give yourself give yourself like really
tiny personal projects that you can pull
off and constantly make stuff like make
things that you're able to finish and
each time you'll sort of learn something
new and each time you should probably
like throw in a little small challenge
to yourself if you want to learn to like
tackle and a project and I mean I think
I did like 100 15-second videos just to
learn After Effects and I would make
stuff that I would never show in public
but it did teach me a lot and how to use
the program and how to use it really
fast
um so Florida and us thanks I had the
biggest smile on my face during your
answer we are so excited about your
topics awesome thanks um
Theo asked what some a surprising thing
you learned while researching these
video is something that might have
shifted the way you listen to music or
genre music I mean I would say the most
recent example is like this smooth jazz
story this I came up with this idea for
that video because I really wanted to do
a series on jazz and I didn't know I
knew that some of the stories that I
wanted to tell like the John Coltrane
Giant Steps video I always had in mind
to do but I kind of wanted to know what
people outside of music wanted
you know about chess and so I gave out
the survey to my co-workers actually
like a little Google survey and I was
like asked a series of questions and
asked them to say like what are their
biggest questions about jazz and every
single person I kid you not it's like
what why do people think smooth jazz is
like elevator music or like what what's
up with smooth jazz um I was like oh my
god I don't want to make a video on
smooth jazz this is so embarrassing
people are gonna hate me for it and I
ended up through the process of
reporting that video like that's so
overwhelmed with how much information
there was on the subject and turns out I
really love smooth jazz I just didn't
realize it so I would say often I feel
like I should probably dig into more
genres that I think I don't like and
kind of figure out ways to really like
come to some sort of appreciation for
them so maybe country music is next I
never listened to country music and I
would really love to figure out how to
still how to tell stories around that
genre and figure out ways that I
probably do really appreciate it
Charlie spent asks what would you say
your favorite TV soundtrack is favorite
soundtrack artists as well
TV soundtrack for sure has got to be the
Nick it was a short-lived show on he was
like HBO or Cinemax and the the composer
for it was cliff Martinez who has done
some like really incredible soundtracks
and I would say if there is one
soundtrack that I've always recommended
to people it's the TV show the neck
which is Kay and I seek a starring Clive
what's the same Clive Owen yeah
starring Clive Owen a really awesome
soundtrack and cliff Martinez has done a
really like a lot of really cool stuff
but for the most part he's worked
with Steven Soderbergh who is one of my
favorite directors so Alexis asks of all
the videos you made which one is your
favorite and why oh my god I would say
you know it didn't I mean it didn't do
as like well as my other ones but I
would say my favorite video in terms of
this story was probably the orchestra
hit video I think it's because I thought
about it for such a long time and I'm so
glad I actually just made it and I think
one of my most exciting moments like the
most the coolest person I've ever
interviewed or one of the coolest people
was Peter Gogol who invented the
Fairlight which is like one of the most
important synthesizers of the 80s and
it's one of my favorite like like I said
eras of music to to study and so talking
to Peter Peter Vogel via Skype was like
a cool nerdy moment for me Rex
asks could you please do a video about
prog rock I loved Dark Side of the Moon
and 2ts songs and would love to learn
more that's so interesting I I was just
researching or like looking at the
Wikipedia page of this artist it's like
an Italian prog rock artists called
Goblin and Tionne just like me the
weirdest place and they have been like
really sampling heavily sampled and
hip-hop music and it's kind of a weird
thing where a lot of progressive rock
artists have found their way into into
hip-hop songs in some way shape or form
and maybe that could be a cool story
Spring Bay ass
what was the story behind you doing an
episode about kpop I haven't seen it but
heard about it you should watch it so we
have this entire season on Netflix of
explained and we cover all sorts of fun
stories and the story behind me doing an
episode on kpop is that we were trying
to pitch global stories about the
culture and the biggest story in terms
of music globally one of them right now
is the success of kpop and the industry
that South Korea has created around
music and I'd never really listened to
it but when I found super exciting and
really fun is sort of early history of
kpop and it just really made me excited
to tell that story and to talk to a lot
of artists and producers and historians
who have studied Korean music but yeah
if you haven't watched it you definitely
should and there is some really really
really fun early sort of progenitor kpop
which is really starting with a couple
of fun hip hop groups in the nineties in
South Korea what's your favorite k-pop
songs Heon I would say um hey BAE by a
Big Bang I like BIGBANG yeah he doesn't
he you just judged me Charlie classic
science yeah I found that the the k-pop
artists that I was the most like I found
the most interesting which teach dragon
so that was not in an original opinion I
guess millions of people around the
world loved him um
Alexander check out Hank Williams senior
he got me into country after him I found
Waylon Jennings a year ago I thought I
hated country turns out I don't I will
definitely do that I listen to Patsy
Cline all the time and I think she's
worth like one of my favor
artists and I just like I haven't
expanded beyond her in terms of the
country world yeah
vo asks most of us listen to music to
escape our routine work Plus daily life
you listen to music on your free time or
do you
oh sorry I'm like skinny reformatted you
work do you still listen to music on
your free time or do you opt for some
other what something else something else
okay see um I do listen to music on my
free time pretty much I have found
myself this year like listening to the
same things over and over again but if
you follow me on Twitter I just
recommended an artist that I a a hip-hop
artist that I just really got into
recently and I can't stop listening to
his album he goes by J ID but you can
also pronounce it kid and he's from
Atlanta and he has album DiCaprio tunes
like I can't stop listening to it and I
probably won't ever make a video about
it but it's really good CEO asks we need
a list of those repetitive listens okay
I mean I make I mix thought if I play
this all the time but one piece of
feedback that I get is that not
everybody knows on Spotify so I'm trying
to come up with a way to write down
playlists without them being associated
with the platform but right now you can
follow me on Spotify and honestly like
if you follow me you'll probably get a
sense of what I'm listening to and for
the most part that is probably what I
might be working on next in terms of
episodes so a lot of people like a lot
of my friends who followed me will text
me and be like why are you listening to
so much Kenny G and I'm like boy I'm
making a video about smooth jazz and I
kind of have to listen to a lot of Kenny
G so yeah hyung asks what is your
favorite kpop band well I just mentioned
the
bang and I would say they might be one
of my favorites yes
Christopher asked sneak peek of the next
year worm uh let's say it involves
I didn't huh what's a way to like not
give this away it involves Frank Zappa
who's Frank I have to figure that one
Ellen asks where D draw inspiration for
animation and design or your favorite
visual artist who would be your dream
interview oh wow that's a lot of
questions for you get your inspiration
um I really I think one of my biggest
sense pieces of inspiration is just
looking at old advertisements from the
era that I'm researching in music or
looking at album covers I really love
collages and like cut and copy sort of
zine style art so I would say my biggest
piece of visual inspiration is usually
artists that do a lot of really cool
collages so we only have 10 minutes left
which is just interesting to know um
Ashley asks once and for all does
pineapple on pizza once and for all
pizza is horrible and I don't like pizza
so it wasn't for nothing for long some
pizza because I will never eat it really
glad to have given the most
controversial opinion ever in the last
10 minutes of my livestream but now
everybody knows
to us the transition from old older
country like Johnny Cash era to modern
country have some presuppositions about
change have a dim view of pop country
we're still talking about country
alright I think I would love to continue
this conversation Alexander but I want
to get two more questions Shaw
are you still hunting for Forrest Fenn's
treasure no I think actually what I
heard and I don't know if this is true
is that he sort of unofficially called
up the treasure hunt because
unfortunately I was putting a lot of
people at risk who weren't necessarily
prepared to go out into the wilderness
but who knows if it's still out there
I think about it all the time Florian do
you plan to feature in episode uh oh
at the moment no I'd love to be involved
in that show but it will take my time
away from making air worm season two
unfortunately I can't do two things at
once and what I really wanted to next
year is just make a really cool awesome
fun ambitious season to a pure worm on
YouTube and yeah I just I wouldn't be
able to do both of those things at once
Carlos asks what's one story you
desperately wanted to tell but just
haven't found the right way slash
funding such access to do it yet oh that
is a really good question there I think
one thing that I really want to do is a
longer piece about like how to Chandra's
of music that you might not think are
related are really related and what a
lot of that has to require is
interviewing a lot of artists involved
in the history of that genre music so
one story that I really love and I find
fastly interesting is how Punk and hip
hop and they're in the early days of
hip-hop and Punk sort of like
intertwined in New York City I'm just I
like just because they were so closely
located
to each other in New York City but
that's just like a longer story that
might be a little too complicated for a
short-form video yeah it's really
interesting to me if you weren't making
videos about music what would you focus
on um I would probably focus on like
some of my favorite podcasts are just
like off-the-beaten-path stories that
you might not that are more about just
everyday people that somehow become
vastly interesting because of the way
they're told Joe on our team recommended
me listen to the podcast I think is
called heavy weight and I got really
into that format of storytelling and
something along those lines would be
really cool to do um Alexis asks what is
the best comment you read under one of
your videos um I think some of my
favorite comments are just the ones
where somebody appreciated genre of
music that they had it before because of
a video I made so yeah the ones where
they're like oh I hated I didn't think I
really like to sing jazz or I didn't
think I liked rap music but actually I I
think you made this like really
appealing to me or you kind of made me
think about it a different way
so those are always my favorite comments
and one of her professors in college
told me that they've played my video in
their class because that's always
validating Alexis asks what is the best
comment oh I just read that one um
Florian do you have a background in
music history or theory or do you
actually learn things like giant sense
analysis for an episode for the most
part I learned stuff per episode and
then I sort of like build that knowledge
and in my free time teach myself and
watch a lot of YouTube videos and read a
lot of stuff on music theory I've only
recently
during that more this year um but yeah
for the most part I'd teach myself these
things as videos go on I wish I had like
10 extra hours and a day to just spend
reading because I feel like I just don't
have enough time uh
Katrine asks when talking about country
it is Asia anima I learned to love
because my dad are there any you didn't
like in the start but learn to love yeah
so like as I mentioned I definitely
learned when I learned about the history
of smooth jazz I was introduced to
artists like Grover Washington Jr and
Bob James and really cool like
instrumentalists that to me like sounds
super fresh and really cool and I just
never would have discovered them how'd I
not like really dug into the history of
jazz and I would say a lot of the time I
even I I would say I really loved like
all types of hip-hop music but there are
certain artists that I just never I
never really like appreciated in certain
ways and I would say yeah all sorts of
genres sort of come to my attention that
I didn't it's early love before all
right so I think we're going to wrap up
I just want to say thank you so much for
joining the membership program because
like super exciting and this is like the
first live AMA that we're doing but
we're going to get better at it and I
was sort of the guinea pig and you all
were too so thanks for being a part of
it and thanks so much Theo for and all
of you for all of your awesome comments
yeah I'm gonna try to go the memory
palace yeah for sure I'm gonna like copy
and paste all these and try to answer
them in some way shape or form later but
I thanks much